when you did a job interviews for  barbell did you interview the people  yourself in the beginning yeah and then  what kind of stuff did you ask them  would you rather [ __ ] your mom or your  dad  it's a JK classic and there is a right  answer one of the questions we asked are  like oh what's the restraints with some  of your weaknesses and this guy goes my  weakness my calves is that not a good  answer for a workout place that sounds  pretty good but I'm like this guy came  dressed with like a dress shirt tucked  into his slacks that's the kind of  response he's giving do you think about  it for a long time because that makes it  better yeah we don't like that  quick-witted [ __ ] do you feel like when  that guy answered you gave him a face I  can't tell so I give faces why it's just  like this  okay